what's happening you bad [__]
it's december 22nd it's a beautiful
[__] wednesday the joint is also
brought to you by my favorite the c b d
lion kinesiology tape gummies capsules
the cream i mean listen they're [__]
tremendous they've helped me for years
i'm sick and tired of talking about them
they have cbd patches that you can place
on different parts of your body that
need like i put a patch on my [__] uh
leg above my knee that [__] high b
muscle whatever the [__] it is
muscle anyway do yourself a favor go to
cbdline.com right now
pressing code joey
church or joint and get yourself 20
delivered right the house you don't want
to start the year with no [__] cbd
gummies to help you relax cbd lion is
the way to go and from the heart of new
jersey the joint is brought to you by
draftkings it's the end of the year and
uncle joy wants to make sure you end up
in the [__] black draft king
sportsbook is the official sports
betting part of the nba and the nfl has
a gift that will certainly put a [__]
you in a holiday spirit listen i love
[__] draftkings why they have the
social network before you bet they have
a stats hug they have a stats [__]
hub they help you they teach you how to
[__] gamble they tell you how to
control your [__] urges and let me
tell you something they care about you
new customers can bet just fight off on
any nba team and 150 and free bets and
there's some [__] good games this
weekend so it's a great way to put some
extra jingle in your [__]
pockets the bowl games are coming and we
got some great nfl tomorrow night
saturday day sunday day if the sports
book isn't available in your state yet
you can christmas and still be married
you can win huge cash prizes with
draftkings daily fantasy basketball
contest
listen that daily fantasy is [__]
tremendous just like that casino
blackjack with a live [__] dealer
draftkings is giving all their new
customers millions of dollars in total
prizes at on the fantasy app so do
yourself a favor download the draftking
sportsbook app or download the
draftkings fantasy app whatever is close
to you today use promo code joey j-o-e-y
bet just five hours and then the nba
team
and if you win you'll win 150 dollars in
free bets gary [__] teeth that's
promo code joey j-o-e-y this christmas
week at draftking sports book i listen
between the ball games basketball pro
football oh my god i'm going to make you
some [__] cash you got to be 21 and
older new jersey indiana or pay pa only
listen there's a ton of states tennessee
colorado new customers only minimum five
dollar deposit with a dollar wager
required now one per customer
restrictions apply
see draftkings.com slash sportsbook for
details code joey now if you got a
gambling problem go take care of it
call 1-800 gambler but if not
let's get this party started head to
draftkings and let's win some
[__] getus and now without
further ado
let's get this [__] jam on fire
it's the day before [__] no
it's three days before christmas i'm
[__] [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 22nd of december we
are we got two days of shoplifting
[__] three days before christmas it's
gonna be a great week guys i'm looking
so forward to this i'm feeling so much
[__] better i'm looking forward to
the holidays this year we will not have
any shows next week we're going dark
next week mikey needs to breathe i need
to breathe i gotta look for an office
we're gonna re-fix this one a little bit
change this one around mikey threw in
some speakers
uh some jbl so we could have the album
of the week or the [__] nightmare of
the week that's the album next week i'm
gonna start doing the nightmare album of
the week but uh we got some jbl speakers
in here so we're just getting we're just
kicking off this [__] for 2022
but i just wanted to check in with you
[__] and let you know
everything is [__] beautiful today
is our first annual church reunion
christmas lee syed is coming on for a
little [__] commentary today to wish
you guys all a happy uh
holidays and a great new year you know
it was great talking to [__] lead man
uh
it was just great it was great to see
him he looks like oh so he's all [__]
bone his shoulders are all bony his head
is bigger but he looks [__] beautiful
man he's got a relationship going
not with some crazy [__] [__] from
l.a he had so many crazy [__] people
in his life in l.a just like me that's
what happens he had this chick called
ayahuasca that would call him up and
talk to him about rogan i mean it was
just crazy she just wanted she was dying
to do ayahuasca he had milkshake the
chubby chick that they broke the bed
together i mean there was just so many
[__] weird things i'm so happy
he's around normal people me i'm [__]
happy you guys
sat here with me for [__] nine months
while i was struggling my [__] ass
off and i owe you guys everything people
left some people said i was [__] i
lost it i was just going through a
[__] time in life man it happens and
you're all going to go through it i hope
you don't but we all go through a
[__] period you know rich vaz told me
a couple weeks ago he goes bro it's
stressful when you move
you got up and moved across country with
kids and everything and you know what
it's over i'm happy i did i have such a
good life now in new jersey i know a lot
of people like what the [__] how come
you're not doing stand-up let me tell
you something man
i put my time in
and i'm just enjoying life now like i
told lee in the interview
this is the first time in my life i've
learned how to relax
like i never relaxed in my life do you
know what that's like
since i was 16 since 1979
i never had a [__] breather in my
life i never enjoyed a family that [__]
i had in boulder was all [__] as you
can see you know nobody talks to me from
that family was just a [__] warm-up
starter family
this is my family and i was uh traveling
a lot you know i was in it i was in it
to win it dawg and one day
i thought about
i wanted to see what was more important
my comedy career
or my family and i chose my [__]
family at this point in my life when i
was 30 i would have told my family go
[__] myself if i was 40 i would have
probably done the same but
as you get older you get a little wiser
well that's what they say and you
you look at your life and you could see
more things i mean
getting old is [__] shitty in some
ways but and the other way is it's not
that's the con now when you wake up in
the morning you hear pops and you know
you're [__] everything is different
but
your mind is what you got to keep
healthy and that's what i've done
i struggled to share
but i thought
guys it got to the point you know i love
to read i mean knowledge is power
iacocca you guys know i love to [__]
read
i couldn't even read guys i couldn't
even sit down and read a [__] book
now i'm starting to just go lightly into
books i don't want to get involved in
like those bob lingard's books that are
[__] this thick but he sent me a new
uh led zeppelin book last week that
[__] looks interesting as [__]
and you know i always talk about like
listen i got a lot of favorite bands
i love black sabbath with all my heart i
love judas priests with all my heart i
love the foo fighters i love the [__]
the stones you know
but if i had to compare myself to any
band did you ever do that compare
yourself to any band let me tell you
something for me to do stand up
it's got to be wild
i gotta walk the wild side
that means some people are gonna get i
gotta tell some people that [__] suckers
some people gotta tell them their mother
sucks some people gotta give him the
finger it's a [__] when you're an
animal you're an animal you know what
i'm saying when you're not an animal you
go and you sit with your family and you
do whatever led zeppelin i've always
loved you know why because when they
were out
they were out
they created nine [__] masterpieces
album well eight
in through the outdoor
but whatever i accepted at least robert
plan sang a song for his son but the
point i'm trying to get to is that led
zeppelin lived
a hundred percent and that's why they
were animals up on stage
that goes hand in hand that doesn't work
for jim gaffigan a lot of other comics
you know he's a decent guy jim gaffigan
it didn't work for me when i was doing
comedy i was in the [__] gutter
that's the only way to do comedy what
does that mean that you're out there you
know it's like people who get rich and
and and you'll see the devil's advocate
al pacino
takes the train why because it keeps him
in touch with what's going on
i didn't want to get out of touch like
these [__] guys that's why you see
him and they're talking this nonsense
and all of a sudden they become
political and they want to tell you who
to vote for who gives a [__] about all
that you can't control people's lives i
like what you put out and i always
admired what led zeppelin put out did
you ever see that pictures like they
look wrecked they didn't give a [__]
they were wrecked they were in this to
win this [__]
and one day somebody died they all
realized what the [__] happened
and they went on their own little pass
yeah a lot of people were upset that led
zeppelin didn't perform anymore
but they had done the damage i had done
the damage i lived like a wild man
for 30 years i did blow for 29 years
things i'm not [__] proud of
but that made me the comic that i was
buckwild not giving a [__] [__] your
mother now i see some of those sets and
i'm like
my daughter's gonna see that someday and
she's gonna go what the [__] was my dad
an animal yeah he was a [__] animal
but i know i look like a half a [__] with
this [__] christmas hat on this is
the worst [__] cry i hate wearing
these things but hey
it's christmas you gotta lighten up a
little bit you gotta take the stick out
of your ass that's what christmas is
about i never understood christmas
because i always blamed
not enjoying christmas i'm losing my
parents that's a [__] excuse
that's a [__] excuse
you know and i lived by it for years but
after i had my daughter changed my
[__] mind
christmas is for these [__] kids
right mike who gives a [__] about us i
want a christmas present like i want a
black dick up my ass i don't wanna i
don't i can kill that i'm not gonna be
mad at you if you don't i'm not
christmas is not about us
christmas is about these [__] kids
but in uh [__] closing with you guys
before i bring lee up i don't want to
take too much of your [__] time on a
wednesday
you guys have been great and uh i owe
you
i definitely [__] know you guys for
being down and not being 100 me so 2022
is my [__] year but guess what
it's also your year too
we will check in with you after lee and
say our goodbyes i hope you enjoy this
this kid has become a savage and i'm
really proud of him enjoy lee syed
[Music]
oh [__]
what's up you bad [__] look at
me i look like [__] the grinch you
look beautiful you're down to bones and
[__] what are you down [__]
142 something like wow
and that's all walking dieting
that's a savage you're a new man your
dick group
oh it did
it did it it's fun yeah sure [__] yeah
oh yeah it got to the point when i was
as big as i was i couldn't really reach
it in the shower to turn on the side or
something to reach it and now i can now
i can just see it
like you can see it you can play with it
got a little longer you gain like an
inch and a half no you're getting like
an inch like every 20 pounds i gained a
bunch of inches i'll see you big dick
lee now and [__] oh yeah like [__] uh
the guy from boogie nights and don't
forget i know you got some edibles over
there we're going deep today [__]
oh i wish i
i don't i i don't i mean i'm on my lunch
100 milligrams some sleepy time i don't
understand this lee i really don't abx
puts a 25 milligram sleepy time you know
what this for [__] [__] and
[__] let me explain something if you
want to sleep just take a [__]
hundred
be my guest why would you take a sleepy
time 25 what the [__] is wrong with you
i would eat the whole thing of these at
night like i would put this whole thing
in a [__] tee it's like 400
milligrams jesus sleep for two days who
gives a [__] take a chance columbus dick
[__] it's the holidays it's the 12
days you got to go [__] beep
in fact check it out let's go let's
start this party right now
boom
oh oh
we're going deep in the afternoon this
is the church christmas reunion we ain't
got time to [__] around in this
[__] merry christmas and happy
hanukkah i love it this is it and
[__]
kaboosh we got everything here habush
you know what i'm saying we got some you
know how about a bush means [__] in
armenia
really yeah i'm telling everybody
i won't i had no idea i just talked to
bergie i'm gonna have an interesting
[__] ride home [__]
there you go salud
these are 150 apiece these strings
no they're not yes they are it's 600 for
the whole thing you get four strings
that's a hundred oh wow 400 let me see
what the [__] is that camp
right right there
so 600
the anxiety's done the depression is
done i'm ready to slick 20 22
i'm gonna stab somebody just out of
[__] respect i think it's time
to make the i'll stab him with like a
nail file like it won't be deep like an
inch oh good like one of those you know
the little [__] thing that you take
the toe jam out of your toe with on your
nail cutter
sure there's a little hook to it right
there just hook a [__] in the
nose it's a small felony you give him 10
g's he disappears
i love it i hope that worked out for you
i don't know it will it will do you know
this is being recorded i don't give a
[__] i gotta impose my will into 2021
and i was at a [__] coleman 2021
after year i didn't tell nobody to suck
my dick
i didn't tell nobody go [__] themselves
i didn't tell nobody that mother smells
like a dead rat
you know i didn't do anything i just
took [__] from people like a half a [__]
that i am but now i'm unloading are you
going to bring back the voicemail
message if you're not a doctor my lawyer
my agent don't leave a [__] mess go
[__] yourself you piece of [__] calling
me
send a tape go [__] yourself i am so
happy
i am out of that world lee i am [__]
ecstatic it took me like 12 months to
unwind
from the 23 years of [__] lies and
just did [__] that i was given to
but i'm settled
and i'm home
so i hope to see you next january after
you come back from mexico you're coming
down for a weekend
wait until those numbers drop down the
omaron variant me you and mikey gonna go
to el nido
eat some black ink pasta
i'll be there in six hours i don't know
january garlic
and [__] the chicken at this el nido
place is so white
it's so grown like organically when you
look at somebody eating the chicken you
go how [__] white is that chicken
it's tremendous it's better than that
place in l.a we went to with yol i don't
want to i don't want to badmouth them
because i liked it but that
starts with the v
versailles okay i don't know if we want
bad
jesus christ that's not even cuban
that's [__] i don't even know that's
like 18 different references
that sucked that place that's oh wow i
thought it was delicious i didn't know i
mean
garlic chicken they can't [__] up i mean
yeah has grill on the chicken it's great
black beans they even [__] up a little
bit but i'm just you know what oh i went
to like you're talking about the cuban
place
i was talking about versailles but we
did also go to that place in uh on the
east side i think that had the pork that
you liked the pork chunks
the cochinito
oh yeah that's a great place that girl
is still my friend on facebook he fired
her cousin
he fired
because she's like a freak you know she
goes to jiu jitsu she lifts weights
oh they fired her so now she's on
[__] tour she hits me up she's
beautiful i love it at that great kid
man
that's awesome all those pork chunks
were second to none
those are the ones i bought from my
wedding
i served those pork chunks at my wedding
dog [__] around with ralph's fried
chicken with with ice with ralph's fried
chicken and canthus pastrami i i catered
to all the [__] races
the brothers with the chicken the
[__] pastrami with the jews and
[__] the other one with the spanish
people who came black beans and rice
fried bananas
right at the wedding well that's because
everyone thinks i'm crazy all i look at
on instagram now is pictures of food and
for some reason it's all jersey places
that pop up and you tell me all the time
you sent me pictures of the jewish deli
you sent me and that's like the only
thing you actually
take pictures of is food you you take
pictures of the food that looks so
goddamn good
i can't wait to come to jersey i'm gonna
gain like eight pounds in two days who
gives a [__] i don't think it's worth it
see that's what i would say to you if
you eat that california food and you
gain weight you feel [__]
bad when i put two pounds on after i
went down nato i'm like [__] it
oh yeah you earned who gives a [__] who
earned it we earned it it's probably
[__] muscle weight
i don't need desserts lee so it's not
like i really attack
things like that like i watch my weight
i really watch things you know and
listen we're human anybody who's dieting
or anybody who's trying to lose weight i
mean lee's the [__] specialist but
you gotta see daylight once in a while
and i'm not like i go to this place late
that you would understand as soon as we
went in there
you would understand what i'm saying
the place is called the marlborough
diner okay
they have pretty good food you know but
like if you go in there like they have
great eggs great everything but they
have skillets there
and i ordered a skillet a couple weeks
ago and i realized something that what
you wanted to eat
when you were 25
is not what you're gonna eat when you're
in your 50s you just you know you you
evolve on food yeah
but this skillet reminded me of
how i ate like whoever the person who
recommended it to me
he's a great guy and i thought the the
skillet was shitty
you know like it was just too much bacon
it's four types of cheeses oh that
sounds great i don't know there's a
thing it's too much bacon dog it's on a
better tater tots
cheese covered with bacon ham and
sausage
[__] and then they put the two eggs on
top of that i'm not kidding you the
thing comes out like this
all right i went there and when they
unveiled it i go oh
this is great
i would have ate this as a 23 year old
that you know you know when you get fat
when you're 28 you eat anything tater
tots with cheese you don't see it i
would
that was bad 32 i would have eaten i'd
eat that right that sounds delicious i
would have ate it at 32 also but you
could see that i ate it and i had to
bring i had to run errands and i had to
run right home with mercy and [__]
[__] green
diarrhea it went right through me
because my body was in shock from it
like my body can't take that anymore you
you're going to notice as you get older
that the [__] you liked as a young guy
whether it's sundays like carvel i love
carvel but i gotta
i buy the cartwheels
the flying saucers i bring home for kids
when they come over i just give out
flying saucers and i get the cups with
the sundae that's what i eat now i just
eat a flying saucer a week with
sprinkles around it the vanilla ice
cream with the chocolate cookie that's
all i need but i thought i was gonna be
there every night eating [__]
milkshakes and
is you had when we were hanging out you
would have more edibles as snacks than
actual snacks like if you got hungry and
an edible you're like well we might as
well have another [__]
we might as well keep it alive with this
brownie or this dog you know how many
nights i [__] went home and ate
munchies and just ate edibles
it was a chocolate bar or whether it was
brownies because you're already deep
you can't get that deeper yes you can no
you can't nobody ods on thc
we almost did though i was going to say
that i think there might be a proof
otherwise of that but god i don't that's
i can't control it i just can't i'm i'm
i'm going to mexico next week and i'm
bringing edibles just so i can take full
advantage of the of the all you can eat
[__] i'm gonna i'm gonna call the room
service because i've never i don't i
don't think i've gotten room service
ever
so i'm gonna i'm gonna call them like
every three hours when i set alarms to
wake up just have them send me something
oh yeah just and just
do me a favor just when you get there
give the guy a 50 bill it's mexico i
haven't seen a 50
in 20 years give them a 50 and get a
belt they go listen every time i ring
the bell i want you to come just i'm not
going to call you i'm just going to ring
the bell and every time you come out
throw your 50 it's like a novelty you
know i'm making your week you're making
my week i always had a fantasy of having
a butler and i can't really afford one
but this on vacation you know i could
throw 300 your way so every damn i'm
gonna ring the bell from my room
whatever you're doing dancing making
burritos you're gonna stop what the [__]
you doing
and you're gonna come up and bring me my
[__] flouters you know what i'm
saying i'm gonna order some exotic
mexican [__] oh well that's because
that's why you you always tip people you
tipped like uber drivers a lot of money
you tipped everybody money and no one
because this is all-inclusive so i like
my my girlfriend has done it a few times
she says like you don't even have to tip
anybody so you're right if i think if i
give anyone like a 10 or 20 they're just
going to be knocking on my door do you
want this or like i'm uh i'm because i
was thinking about it dude like we
i think for the first six out of the
eight years we didn't even take this
week off
no we're taking the next week off
see and like you you just look so much
happier like even just this time of year
you're always happy with mercy and your
wife and everything but like starting
right before thanksgiving you'd be a
little bit grumpy like no one [__]
answers the phone this time of year
can't wait till this is over
hate it
oh see i is everyone everyone else is
excited to get a wing like god damn and
i hate this goddamn time of year i
[__] hate it i hate being
just
i'll tell you what i'm getting used to
it
right you have to you have to get used
to it if not you [__] kill yourself
from you know anxiety mm-hmm i'm
starting to learn how to relax
while you're starting to learn how to i
mean dog
you know it's over when you get a chair
i would
i have an old man chair and i sit on a
recliner and i cover myself with a
blanket i never in my life
thought i would put a blanket on my legs
because i'd be cold
but guess what i'm doing that now okay
give a couple hot cocoa too sounded no
i'm not that much of a [__] i just i
[__] got coke zero at night that's it
i'm a coke zero [__] one can at
night to get the party going i like the
little bubbly in my throat that's what
they they should mix come with coke like
for girls that don't like come right off
the bat just to help them adjust so the
[__] goes down with the coke and it
tickles their throat and they're like oh
i like to come not really but with
coca-cola mixing it
it tickles my throat i don't even know
what the [__] i'm talking about but i'm
just inventing things as we go along
it's a new energy drink oh [__]
i can i can hear it from here god i
missed that
it was i i must be in that high i'm
gonna have to if i didn't have to go
back to work after this i'd do it [__]
i got high sunday i gave i went to jimmy
florentine's house and i brought 15
milligram gummies
right 15 milligrams
15 i swear to god there were 15 a piece
so i gave one guy one and one guy said i
only eat one and within 20 minutes i
looked at them and they were both like
and i'm like these guys are looking a
little [__] up for 15 milligrams so
that's donors you know i went over and
talked to them and the one guy's jewish
his name is ish i love him he's like
[__] joey diaz you're gonna [__]
kill me you're not gonna be happy till
you kill me with these things i'm [__]
up right now he was saying all this [__]
to me so i looked at him and i go if he
got that [__] up from 15 i'm gonna eat
this [__]
so i ate the whole bag it was 270 left
it was 300 for the bag
and 15 a piece minus [__] 30 that's
270. i came home and i threw the whole
[__] bag down i think i don't know
who i was watching play football who
played sunday night
um
was it the saints and the it was the
saints buccaneers it was the buccaneer
game i was high as [__] i felt like my
neck and [__] getting high you know like
when you eating edibles and i did a
couple of [__] freeze pipe hits
outside tremendous my freeze pipe is
starting to get stuck so i think i have
to
yeah you have to take the [__] free
that's your listen i love freeze pipe i
don't know great things about it this
guy
excuse me i'm sorry there's two that
look i'm not lying to you there's only
two knocks
i i'm always scared that something's
gonna break
there's so many tubes that you're scared
you get high and something's gonna break
and that's what happens when you get
high you drop the tube you drop the
[__] thing
and the other thing i don't like is the
way it clogs like you just go out there
one night and surprise i'm clogged
so you have to take it and put in hot
water with alcohol i've had that happen
twice i actually i got real i got real
high on it and i took it out of the
freezer and it was a little wet and i
was trying to connect it
and because i have the bubbler and you
have to connect it and it slipped and it
break but they they they sell uh
replacement pieces so i just got a new
piece and it worked great the clogging
thing
to me you can't smoke it right out of
the freezer you got to give it a minute
that's usually how it gets for me
because i they sent me the bong but i'm
kind of scared of using that bomb i'm
scared of that bung that bong is real
that bong has three compartments like an
ak-47 that's what they call that bung
that bang's on ak-47 that'll kill
tons of [__] kids have you tried it
no are you sticking with the bubbler
yeah no i'm sticking with the bubbler
for now i'll bust out the bong later on
trust me it's a beautiful bunk yeah
they're beautiful [__] heavy pieces
but the bong has like three pieces i'm
gonna eliminate the one because it's not
necessary when you have three pieces and
you're [__] trying to smoke and you
look like a trombone like i feel like
the guy from the rolling stones or the
trombone and [__] bobby sacks whatever
his name is and so i [__] take the
one middle part off just put the freezer
apart and it's like a foot and a half
you know right if that if you don't if
you don't get high on that then it's
time to jump on heroin give me a call
and i'll send you to a dealer in newark
yeah and it's good it makes the weed
last longer
am i like between smoking from joints to
those i don't know what it is but i get
a lot higher on the freeze pipe i do
three hits of the freeze pipe and i'm
right good i roll a joint and i go
outside i got to be honest with
everybody
three quarters of the joint i just throw
the other piece away
so really weed away so i said [__] it
why am i wasting weed i might as well
hit it with the [__] freeze pipe and
you know
what did we end up doing with that
remember we had a film canister with all
of our roaches at one point that was
literally we couldn't close it did we
give that away do we i forget we did so
much of that stuff we literally had like
a film canister filled with roads i got
a box filled with roaches now
but i can't put another roach in there
when i first came from california i
thought i wouldn't get great weed again
so i was like just throwing roaches in
this box one day i looked it's a [__]
box
i'm gonna clean it out for the new year
and just smoke all that old weed cause
there's some good [__] weed in there
and now the roaches got hard like you
can't that [__] rock hard with that
resin on it you open those [__]
up put them in the freeze pipe
it'll be like your spotify year in
review but it'll just be all the weed
you smoked that's it i [__] love it
man that hard time there was a point
where i couldn't even smoke if i smoked
my heart would start beating [__]
dramatically and i remember one time the
fourth of july
i took a 10 milligram edible and i went
to these people's houses in the
afternoon dog i had to leave
no
no idea how sick i was you have no idea
my heart would beat like a drum while i
was talking to you it was horrible
i never want to go through that [__]
feeling again and what it did to me so
i'm done but i'm happy that i'm eating
edibles now like like wait i'm not back
to where we were i was gonna say you
just said you're dumb but you just ate
two or three edibles i'm excited because
i saw you you know what i'm saying i got
a flashback
so how do you do what you gotta do i
used to love that you'd call me at like
three for an eight o'clock podcast
you're like we're not taking edibles
time we're we're gonna take a bullet
breather i'd get you'd get there eight
o'clock you'd beep i'd let you in you
just throw edibles you're like time to
take some medicals like it would take a
five hour break that's the only thing
that's all we need that's all five hours
but we must have broke a lot of records
in california we broke a lot of records
we surprised a lot of people a lot of
people thought we were [__] around
and we weren't [__] around we were
going deep on a day people accused me of
eating fake edibles oh my god it was
good you cannot eat those stars those
are fake stars [__] look at lee
it's like nobody believed it but then
people [__]
yeah you know
everybody was patient zero either ida
ended up in the hospital [__] sarah
tiana owen benjamin he's still walking
somebody saw him in [__] spain the
other day walking around asking if he'd
get some edibles don't eat joey diaz
edibles he's like a [__] i don't
haven't even seen owen benjamin he got
kicked off of everything i think so
where is
he live in the woods that's crazy that
that edible [__] them up that much but
that's what those edibles do they make
you see the devil
and you change it's like becoming a
born-again christian all those
born-again become christians anyway they
take the taste of cake [__] out of that
mouth of l.a whenever you see those
[__] actors become born again
christians a scientologist or some
religion trust me they're trying to do
anything to take this taste of sperm out
of their [__] mouth because that
producer sperm stays in your mouth for
years speaking of which i got to ask you
something
i'm a little [__] up from time to time
i wouldn't trust any of my judgment what
do you think about this whole krishna
thing
this is [__] disturbing it disturbs
the [__] out of me i mean maybe i don't
know what it is chris is mr big from
the city
i mean look i i don't know i never met
the guy but i [__] really sympathize
for that guy
you know
we're letting this [__] go out of
control and what did they say he did he
said that he sexually was inappropriate
with two women in 2015 and 2001
or something like that i don't know
listen listen i'm a [__] [__]
i've always been an [__]
i was on coke for years
you know and that's not an excuse but it
does change your mindset on things it
does
make you look at things a little
differently when you're high anything
does
anything affects your judgment calls so
i'm reading this that some chick raised
their hand from 2000
and some chick from 2005 or something
like that and i'm like you know what man
so two anonymous
women called into hollywood reporter and
told them this
that means anybody could call
at any time
and your career is ruined
okay we didn't look into this
we didn't [__] check the stories out
we didn't give them a lie detector test
we didn't do anything we just took these
women's work not listen i'm not putting
any women down at all i have a daughter
i have a wife and i help someday my wife
my daughter's not in this predicament
but you just could call a [__]
hollywood reporter and they'll
tell the world that you were involved in
that and everybody lets you go
right i mean in his case his agency
his he lost 12 million dollars on a
tequila deal
he lost his role on the equalizer i mean
you know they took away his peloton
commercial he did all this [__]
isn't that a little too [__] rough
for somebody who just went on
allegations first of all this is the
united states of america i don't know
nothing about nothing but this is the
united states of america i'm a tax
paying united states of american i
[__] went to prison i paid my debt to
society yes i have a felony but that was
20 years ago so now i have a word again
and i could give my opinions we [__]
fought hard we did a lot of things for
george washington and thomas jefferson
and ben franklin all these [__] humps
to write this constitution everybody
forgets i have an accuser i have the
right to face that accuser i have the
[__] right i don't know what the [__]
people have forgotten you come at me
with something like chris not and i'm
gonna say the same [__] thing to you
i'll [__] sue the hollywood reporter
and i'll sue those two [__] chicks
and that's fine until you're innocent
until proven guilty in this [__]
country last time i [__] checked i
went to prison i worked through a legal
process and i'm here now and i'm very
[__] proud of that so i deserve the
mouth to talk i've been through legal
[__] process in this country and it's
a great legal process and i believe in
it 150 [__] percent yeah it's got
some loopholes but this
is not the american way
i
don't believe in cancer culture i
believe in punishing somebody or letting
them go away for a year to think about
what they did but who the [__] are you
to put you know
someone
it's very it's scary because you're
right you have you have a daughter you
have a wife you would want
their
if anything god forbid ever happened
you'd want people to listen to them and
and take their word for it but
it's also
it's
it seems like some people and women are
probably going to deal with this too
it's not fair to the other
half of that story
because they they no one will see that i
just watched law and order last week and
it was this teacher got accused of of
molesting kids and that turned out the
kids made it up and but
the they
they don't hear from that when when it
gets debunked it's not as big of a story
uh we just a comic a week or two ago
just got kicked off of a show he had
been on for years because of some
allegations that who knows if it was
true or not i i
you oh you see his friends online saying
it wasn't true but it's just
i we i wish
that the people who really care about
this and there are people for good
reasons who care about it
made as big of a deal
to make sure that the story gets out
that dave portnoy thing happened earlier
this year
it's it is very scary to think that you
don't have a chance to defend yourself i
i think that's that's wrong or at least
when you prove your point that it's not
publicized in the same way
i mean you went through it right before
we left you went through it because of
that i stuck up for myself to the
[__] end to the [__] end and i
don't give a [__] yeah there was a girl
and yeah she sucked nick what do you
want me to [__] do
that's what she wanted to do that was
her way of doing it we had a great time
but it wasn't enough did she raise her
hand no because everybody knew exactly
what we're doing we spoke the week after
the allocation the allegations came out
and we're like can we [__] believe it
was a [__] joke she's married she's
got kid now she's on with her [__]
life if not i would have put a front and
center to tell all these [__]
to go [__] themselves and that's exactly
what i did i'll fight for myself to the
end if i'm right
right if i'm wrong i'll apologize and
i'll take my [__] lumps but
you have to prove that allegation don't
[__] tell me that you told your
friend and she told you to go to the
hospital
if somebody raped you you go to the
[__] hospital
you don't want to say anything then you
don't
but you know all of a sudden he gets put
in a new popular tv show he dies on the
episode
and all of a sudden two women call down
there they just [__] remembered about
the story they just [__] remembered
about this story
doesn't work for uncle joey and
you know i feel bad for chris not i
don't know him personally but
i don't feel you should cut somebody's
legs off
for an allegation there's no arrest
was there an arrest there was no arrest
there was no police paperwork but uh
they contacted the police in la and they
did a search through all this [__] there
was no allegations so you know what for
you people who gave up on kris not i i
a3 agency cbs all you [__]
you're a bunch of [__] pukes and
you're going against the american
[__] belief
that you have to [__] prove
proof i don't care if i did something
wrong and you prove it i kidnapped the
dude and i took my [__] humps i
wanted to leave the country and go to
nicaragua like you know whatever his
name is and i'm starting to get high a
little bit these [__] edibles hit you
hard i'll be like [__] what's his
name
tyrone woodley on the [__] mat
holy [__] that's what the edibles need
to do to me you end up like tyrone
woodley on the [__] mat that was
embarrassing i i like what paul's doing
he's knocking out all these ufc guys
embarrassing that company with one shot
making triple of what the ufc fighters
make and i'm happy a guy like that
is going up against dana because that's
what people needed to see people are
starting to pay attention to this kid it
sounded a little crazy at first i'm like
i'm not going to order those fights
they're all novelty fights to me i don't
want to watch
but he's making some [__] sense here
and he's making some noise well he uh he
gets a lot of hate for being a youtube
person boxing but what what i just
realized this week was he's doing like
if i had millions of dollars in the bank
yeah i'd go and try to be a stand-up i
just i i can't be broke i don't like
being broke or that that i don't have it
in me for that struggle for 10 15 20
years but if i had money
that's what i would do he has all the
money he'll ever need
and he
hires the best trainers in boxes all the
time
i mean that's what it seems like so it
makes sense that he's getting good
i mean
it
he knocked i i only saw the replay but
that was like a legit knockout i know
some people said all the fights weren't
as good that he knocked the he knocked
him straight out dog when hit him with
that shot you hear it
and if you look closely you can see the
sweat fly off his [__] head
yeah sweat just goes joint then he just
drops to the floor i like tyron he was
always a great fighter in the ufc i
don't know if it's fixed or not
i don't know what's going on there's
like a video of him going yeah
yeah i'm i don't know you know what's
going on but
whatever he's doing he's embarrassing
and people are [__] taking notice
going holy [__] this guy's not i hope he
fights anderson silva if listen if he
beats anderson silva
then i don't know what the [__] to tell
you but he's a big kid he's strong
he trains and
i don't know in some people's eyes he
may be doing the right [__]
thing you know what what do you think
about his brother i don't know if it was
confirmed or not but his brother was
rumored was gonna fight mike tyson
listen uh mike tyson's a [__]
savage even at 55 however old he is yeah
i think that if he hits you with 70 of
his old power
you're still gonna have a hard time
squeezing the ball the rest of your life
that's just me i think mike tyson
could still blast but i admire mike
tyson because
he hasn't jumped on this [__]
bandwagon
he knows that it's you know he's a young
kid
you're gonna go in there and get beat up
by a young kid you can't see when you're
over 40 your eyes aren't
the same your reflection uh reflective
you know the blocks aren't the same
that's why they don't tell you i was
watching rocky and they turned him down
for his [__] license the last time
before he was gonna fight and uh
some game or something like that creed
too i was watching it the other night on
whatever the [__] every night on b-e-t
you either got creed or you got hustle
and flow you know me i gotta support the
brothers so i turn on a little bt they
get a little money nobody forgot about
it uncle joey what
do you love b-e-t i love it all your
movies are recorded from b-e-t
i love b-t and [__] they got
hustle and flow on that [__]
every night that's one of my favorite
[__] movies hustle and flow that's a
sensational movie
is that the only reason you were mad to
leave valet you had to leave leave your
dvr you had stuff on your dvr for years
oh i was pissed i had bruce lee [__] i
had a thousand sons of anarchy on there
i had [__] those i had the exorcist
on there
i had a bunch of movies that come on i
had the pope of greenwich village
anything that doesn't come on a lot
even if it comes on a regular tv show
alpha i don't get well it's good
commercials give us a [__] this movie is
better with commercials than that [__]
you're watching on abc the goldbergs you
know what i'm saying who gives a [__] if
they fire them from the goldbergs that
kid is so [__] happy now listen i've
known him for years i knew his wife for
years she used to cast me and [__] i
would talk to him
if i had to say something about that
[__] kid
is that he's a little goofy he's an
improv guy
so they are a little [__] goofy he's
a hugger you know he was saying a joke
that i say all the time my [__] hurts
at least he was better than me he was
saying his vagina hurts
you know what i'm saying that's why they
fired him
can you imagine me on that show
ugh i'm getting old my [__] hurts i
gotta go wash my [__] how many times
have i [__] said that he at least was
a decent individual he's like i gotta go
wash my vagina
big difference you know what i'm saying
i didn't know see like that's that's
what the like the reason i remember when
we had the idea for the church one of
the first things you said was you wanted
to do it at six in the morning because
you wanted to get to people first
because the news is always depressing
and
that's
i honestly
try to stay as far away from anything in
the news as possible and i
i don't i don't i don't my mom and my
dad both watch it at night so sometimes
i'll be stuck in there watching the
local news with them but they don't
really get into anything that depressing
um
but i
i just can't do i
if people get obsessed with it it's just
and that's what that's why i think
people
bail on everyone so quickly because if
companies don't then there's going to be
protests and then there's
they they just know that there's going
to be such backlash that it's not worth
it to them even even if they like the
person the last two years i've seen
nothing but
people walking away from people
okay and that's not how we were raised
that's not how your mother raised you
that's not how your father raised you
from these [__] agents taking
people's money and then dumping them
when something comes up oh you said
something about kobe bryant you [__]
call it you get on twitter and you tell
them i'm backing my client 100 percent
he made a mistake and that's it move on
with your [__] life
allegations of some girl saying oh well
he tried to hit on me did he [__] you
know did he grab your tent no then what
are we talking about he tried to hit on
you he's a man you're a [__] woman
you're 20 whatever you called him when
you were 17 you wanted dick he told you
to take a year off to go out and [__]
some young kids and come back when
you're 20. you know what do you want me
to [__] tell you what do you want me
to tell you somebody who was nasty would
have [__] you and now we're mad at
dalia with matt and what is what did
this all happen what has happened since
we've canceled all these people
delea is back he's working
uh brian callan is back i'm happy he's
working they dropped the lawsuit there's
no more people complaining because they
got nowhere
they got nowhere people thought that i
was gonna come oh i'll make up something
that joey d has raped me and then no
it's not gonna go anywhere
you didn't call the cops you didn't put
a tissue in your [__] they don't have a
[__] rape kit you know what what are
we talking about here and i'm listening
i have daughters i have best friends
that are women i love [__] women with
all my heart some people i talk to women
more than i talk to men
but this shit's got to stop we just
can't believe every [__] i'm gonna
start saying allegations pretty soon a
girl grabbed me in 1982 at a comedy club
you know in 1991 let's see how [__]
people like it or what like what if like
it was like remember when they used to
say jane doe jane and john doe
what if they did that and then run
through the whole process and it's
proven then have it come out it just
didn't happen come on let's take the
[__] to court
if he definitely touched you and you
have witnesses and
everybody passed the law that lie detect
the test let's move to the next level
i'll take that
i will take that i can live with that
but what they did to this poor guy and
what they're doing to people and some
people listen some people were running
a little crazy for a long time
and they just needed a wake-up call and
i understand that too
but taking somebody's life away from
them is not the [__] answer
no i mean what is
hopefully you have enough saved up for
the rest of your life at least a few
years no like i mean that's like what
are you gonna do
i'm gonna collect social security like
every other whole [__] [__] i don't
know you i'm just saying like in this
scenario like if you can't if you can't
get a job if the first thing that comes
up when you google somebody is that it's
not gonna be you're gonna be doing
nothing you're gonna be
you can't you won't be able to make a
living i lost a book deal over that
[__] tweet
i lost a book deal with a major
publisher
over that thing that happened 18 months
ago you remember we lost all our
sponsors
i mean the only sponsor that broke my
heart was man's uh
me undies
i was with me undies for a long time i
always gave them great service even
after they canceled me i continued
wearing their underwears
because i knew where they were coming
from 10 years ago they threw all their
underwear away i get it
but guess what me undies did they made
it up to me and they came back
and they're a great company for doing
that
they realize that wasn't that person you
know time will tell you whether what a
person will do i like when somebody gets
checked
because i'm the type of guy that wants
to see their reaction
the reaction is number one thing
to see if somebody's guilty or innocent
and or and what
their plan is
because what do you mean by that
if somebody makes an allegation against
you
and something like chris not happens
it's great it's over with
and you move on with your life but you
have to take steps to come back
and they have to be careful steps they
have to be loving steps
and
if this is if you're guilty
is if you're guilty if they accuse you
of something and you're guilty
you can't live in your house the rest of
your life and you can't stay in there
with the shades drawn
so eventually you got to make something
and make it [__] happen
and you just come out slowly and look at
louis ck i give him all whatever whether
he is guilty
or innocent he went away
and then he said to himself you can't
stop me
you can't stop me from doing what i love
you can't stop me from being being me
chris not is no longer an actor
that's a little bit
[__]
not good
for somebody who didn't get processed in
the court system
you process me in the court system
i'm good i got processed in the court
system for kidnapping lee
i came out from there i made a few
[__] mistakes i realized what i had
done
and then when people read my book
they're gonna notice that the rest of
those 30 years
was me trying to be a decent individual
you had side cuts there was help you
know i sold some coke to whitney houston
there was some [__] humps and bumps
but it takes time and as long as you
wake up every morning in 2022 thinking
that you want to be a better person you
want to be the best version of lee i
want to be the best person of mikey
klein i want to be the best joey diaz
that's all you could do and that and the
people who are going to leave listen i
had a dear friend
contact me a girl the girl from
spider-man 2
that i became friends with that little
girl that we were tight for [__]
years and she was like me too me too you
know when the [__] thing she
contacted she's all these things true i
go what do you think i knew you when you
were 14 did i try anything on you have i
ever acted and she goes well you didn't
and you were always a gentleman and you
were nice to my mother but i have to go
with the rest of the pack i'm following
you
you know and nittany by listen she's a
[__] [__] for doing that she's
the girl that wrote the letter to try to
get that [__] kid banned the nerdist
right she's the one i remember
so yeah she [__] tried to bury that
kid and that kid [__] pulled that off
they tried to cancel a nerdist and he
was like really i'm gonna get all my
[__] ex-girlfriends and i talked in
support still
and that's what happened and the nerd
just got everything back but that girl
tried to cut his legs off
did you
by any chance watch the new south park
uh specials they put out about coven
no
you it's hysterical i don't know if you
like south park but the the conclusion
this isn't a spoiler was that we have to
give everyone a little bit of slack we
have to like we have to we have to cut
people some slack and
i think that is really what's missing i
i really think they hit the nail on the
head is
people just are so quick to get angry
and only see whatever side they
they believe in that they forget that
we're all
people we all make mistakes and yeah bad
ones you deserve to go to jail and
that's what happens but
even with little ones like
friends going away that don't call from
california anymore whatever i just feel
like we don't cut anybody any slack
anymore it's either they love you or
they hate you
and it can flip like that and it's
that's why i'm happy between you and
steve and eric the few people that i've
still talked to from california i know
we're good friends and i'll i'll talk to
them forever it's uh
that we need more people like that to
just cut us some slack
[__] steve someone tried to get him
on here a couple weeks ago zoom didn't
work it's like steve you're tight with
god and your [__] zoom don't work
jesus christ
you know
if you're gonna be tight with [__]
god at least make your zoom work how do
you reach god every [__] day and say
your prayers [__] you would hope
wi-fi would get better if you believed
in god yeah you hope your wife i would
be better and [__] like that
lee i'm really proud of what you did
this year i always knew you had it in
your kid i knew you had it in you it was
just we had to get out of that [__]
hell hole
we had to get out did you see that they
[__] killed somebody two blocks from
the office if you stay on the couch go
up there was a house [__] uh invasion
and they shot a man up there two blocks
from two blocks if you start on in front
of your office and walk up past my old
house right and then the other block
right down that street that went down
oh no they shot a [__] guy in the
house so are you not out of there
i'm thrilled to be out of there i don't
i don't know what it was i mean i think
probably leaving california had
something to do with it every other time
i've lost weight though i just
i got sick of being as big as i was and
i just
i started doing it and
and you said something to me what i was
doing with irish the kettlebells when i
was doing those with him he's like
listen that's expensive why do you keep
doing it and
i don't know why and it's something that
i love to work on and fix but i'm not
good at doing things for myself
when
i don't have anybody else
that's expecting me to do it
so that's why i started that group
to do walk i've done i do walks four
times a week and that's
that's one of the smartest things that
you told me was
like
the workouts don't have to be crazy hard
and the diets don't have to be
intense my my life my diet's been great
you weren't really happy with the diet
right at the beginning but for me it
works
is the one meal a day and the walking
that's literally all i've done because
when you start off i know a lot of
people are going to listen to this
around the new year and they want to
lose weight or get healthier
every time i started it and went to
grilled chicken with rice and broccoli
or no rice
and and trying to do
hit hit workouts or going with a trainer
i hated every second of it there's a
reason i didn't get to be 336 pounds
because i enjoyed working out i just got
off the habit i have always hated
working out and i'm always
i found the walking
gets me a little bit there were days in
l.a joey that i'd be under a thousand
steps
and that that takes some effort to be
under a thousand steps for a day and now
i try to get between three and five
thousand steps a day at minimum
and
and you know what the little changes
it's it's not like that juice fast i
lost 70 pounds in 27 days and then my
legs started to tangle so i stopped but
but now i lose two pounds a week
something like that two and a half
pounds a week now sometimes
and in a year
that i was gonna go through life anyways
i lost 140 pounds and it's like i don't
i'm hoping that i won't put it back on
i'm working really hard on it but you
won't but let yourself eat let yourself
live this lively
you were young you know and i wanted you
to go out there and conquer the [__]
world and you did it
you know it's okay to eat a slice of
pizza what the [__] were you guys
talking about where you going for
denny's where you going
oh no
[__] that [__] you're going to legal
[__] seafood oh i just went i
just went oh i want to give a shout out
i'm sure he listens the uh the food
runner and i'm sorry i forget your name
he was like 16. it was his first job
he had legal seafood because i went to
the one i worked at when i lived here
and the bartender was the same so we
were talking and he came up he's like
listen the food runner got really
excited he's like do you know lee sia
like and joey diaz so he came over we
took a picture and he's he was 16 and he
or 18 tops
and it was uh
it was just
it doesn't happen that much anymore
but like it it still blows my mind like
over a year later that people listen and
watch the church like my life didn't
really change i was a chubby dude in an
apartment same apartment and i got to
meet some cool people
but like just to think back and like
to know how many people watch and listen
to that to us just being crazy
what is is just so cool
i wan i went to jiu jitsu the other day
and i'm in my car
because the guy comes at like five to
twelve and opens the door
and i wasn't thinking much about
anything i was just happy to be there
the guy came open the door i was talking
to somebody on the phone i go listen i
gotta go i gotta run up to jiu jitsu i
got my baggers i'm walking up the stairs
these kids walked past me
like nine of them
and i felt that they stopped i kept
walking straight and i hear
mr diaz
can we talk to you and i look at them
and i go who the [__] said mr diaz they
all got straight up don't ever [__]
call me mr diaz [__] i'm joey
uncle joey they're like yeah
and they all came over i made [__]
videos with them you [__] suckers they
like put a message to our class they
were high schoolers it was the day that
they were going to shoot everybody the
kids were going to shoot everybody and
[__] friday
i saw him at jiu jitsu and i'm like you
crazy [__] and they're like ah
oh my god my little [__] [__]
aren't in school he goes because they
were going to shoot everybody so we
stayed home we're good kids i go that's
right go smoke some dope have a great
day
call slumpkitchen.com
and let them hook you the [__] up jack
jeez i i had something happen it's kind
of like when we one time when we went to
austin i don't know if you remember this
it's the one time they didn't put you in
the doubletree they put you in the in
the like a nice hotel and we went to a
convenience store and the owner was
convinced you were a big [__] wouldn't
take no for an answer i was up in maine
and um i was at a bar
talking with some people from my new job
and they brought up the podcast all this
and that and this mother and son came up
as we were leaving the kid must have
been 13
and said excuse me um
it doesn't happen to me much but i can
tell when someone recognizes me and it's
it's nice i always say hi to them and he
just goes
you look exactly like mall cop
and the mom goes you look so much like
him and it's mother and son out night
would you take a picture with us
i thought they watched the church they
thought i looked like kevin james which
i do but they they i took a picture i
don't know what like they didn't even
think i was him i just took like a
look-alike of kevin james
like ah this must be what joey felt like
all those years with big [__] but at
least they thought you were big [__]
i had people tell me you're a big [__]
i know it you don't want to take a
picture of me because you're a douchebag
i'm like dog that's not me and i
remember spider-man too there was some
people on the on the set taking like a
tour tourist
they would not
take no they took pictures and i'm like
i'm not him
yes it is that's you okay
what are you doing like christmas eve
christmas eve uh we're gonna go make
cookies um i'm excited about that
christmas it's gonna be like my first
real christmas she's making um
french toast but with like cinnamon
rolls she's like making like a french
toast casserole with cinnamon rolls uh
we got we got matching pajamas we're
doing that and then uh we're doing the
jewish christmas later on because her
kids are going to her ex's house so
we're going to get chinese food take
some edibles and watch a movie or
something
and what are you doing with mom anything
mom no mom uh tonight actually tonight
mom and her brother and sister-in-law
are coming over and we're having brisket
and lockies
tonight's today's my weigh-in day so i i
get like i have tuna you'll be so pissed
off i have tuna with light mayo not even
not light amount of mail light
mayonnaise tastes like dirt helmets
makes like male it's good oh i think
well i eat it but i don't like it but
then i i scoop it with rice cakes so
that's my pre-weigh-in meal that's
great the rice cakes that [__] dries
your ass whole lot you know what i'm
saying you ever take a [__] you got no
moisture in it and you're struggling
that's why the dry the rice cakes will
[__] you up i got my first hemorrhoid
this year did you did you take a picture
of it
no i didn't take it but i i [__] got
that preparation h that you have to
stick up your ass and school
it's nice and cool
it refreshes you you didn't have the
girlfriend lick it
no you got to have a little hemorrhoid
oh it went away thank you
you look that little hemorrhoid it
shrinks up it's better than preparation
h you know what i'm saying
merry christmas happy hanukkah what
about dad what's he doing
dad's doing great he's in south florida
i'm gonna see him in february for his
birthday
uh which is right next to yours so that
we're doing great merry christmas to you
are you guys going anywhere are you guys
going to stick around we're doing friday
night at a friends and then saturday
we're going to a big christmas bash some
someone's getting covered but
[__] it
as long as we get a christmas present
yeah i'll have covert next week for sure
yeah as long as it's not you oh don't
say that jesus christ so it's a [__]
two days you sneeze
you took the [__] monochromial [__]
and you're back in four days look at the
nba football this week they're all back
in three [__] days let's hope they're
in better shape than me though yeah you
never know your dick is big it's all
about the dick this set of balls you
look great brother and uh thank you
buddy i'm happy you're living the life
you deserve to be living that's not life
out there there were no women out there
for you you missed paula
you said paul you sent paula picture
your dick that's you should send it take
a picture your dick and go look what
you're missing up there in bakersfield
[__] yeah she's a lawyer i'll
definitely go to jail if i do that
she listen guys he would call me
every day i broke up with her for three
years he would call me you call paula
today
no i didn't call paula oh my god
i love it i still
you know what i i probably should call
her and just see ayahuasca you hear from
her
with the
abortion milk that she had in the [__]
every time she came over it was an
aborted [__] like she just had like 18
abortions
and then you had milkshake who broke the
bed and
she just walked into weight watchers and
said my life is yours
she don't give a [__] my life is yours
they got weight watchers in miami
i'm probably not who knows
oh my god i had so many
crazy women and like i just and they
weren't even crazy it was just i it
wasn't good between her there was a girl
in milwaukee for a couple days
it was
i'm
it's just nice to be with someone like
regular normal like it's it's it's uh
but god i haven't thought about a lot of
those people in a long god damn time
well it's time for you to do a little
while think about ayahuasca and her
[__] aborted [__] and bang one out
tonight
i love you lisa i'm happy you took the
time for a [__] joint christmas
merry christmas special the edibles are
starting to hit me i to take two steps
to the rear and get out of here you know
what i'm saying i'm in the wind
later i love you buddy
merry christmas
your family tell your mom and dad i send
them my love and i'll see you in january
we're gonna do a little sleepover at the
house and [__] eat some good food eat
some short rib
get nice [__] short rib ragu
for masteria
i'll be there whenever first time i ate
the short rib ragu i thought of you the
first time i tasted the lobster ravioli
the lobster gnocchi yet or whatever the
[__]
is tremendous the [__] feast has a
sunday sauce that your dick gets hard as
you're [__] eating and your
hemorrhoid pops but then i'll take you
to the king of kings el nido wait those
pop
what the hemorrhoids yeah mine getting
hot dog you gotta [__] work on the
pop and when they're sucking your dick
you turn around and squeeze the
hemorrhoid and shoots in their cheek
tremendous that's from the 80s you had
to go to [__] in a sex club to get that
somebody squeeze hemorrhoid juice in
your face
that's old school you won't get the flu
for a year it's better than the vaccine
well let's do it then uh thank you buddy
i love you say hi to terry and mercy and
i i hope i don't know if i'll be there
for that but say happy birthday to mercy
when it is she said and uh to say happy
i told today i'm talking to lee you
wanna mess he goes tell him merry
christmas we
because he used to call you we or some
[__] i don't know what you think i love
it and it ended up so i miss i miss all
of you guys and mike i hope you mike has
a a great christmas and new year and
i'll see him in 2022 too one quick one
quick story we're eating a couple weeks
ago mercy had a bully
so i was talking to outside go mel you
know i told him what to say to him and
[__] so florentine and luke are upstairs
eating and
mercy's upstairs eating one of our
girlfriends his own world and mercy goes
terry goes you know you got to use your
head mercy with bully she goes i will
and if he does anything tomorrow i'm
just going to call him a [__] [__]
gym foreign spit his food luke's but his
food
and my wife's like what'd you say and
she goes i'm gonna call him a [__] like
dad told me to write that and i'm like
ah yeah it's gotta be a [__] truck
how how old does she know now is she
gonna be nine
nine
oh my god well and is she still doing
martial arts because i remember when she
was like seven she was like punching and
kicking the [__] out of you yes oh yeah
well that bully's about to be in for a
rude awakening yeah she's got a nasty
[__] arm bar they even throw me a jiu
jitsu her clown she's doing jiu jitsu
now too it's all mixed in with the
program she does
oh no
she got a great [__]
bro we were at the park one day and she
was wrestling with some girl and i
looked over and she was getting an arm
bar i go no mercy
what the [__] mercy
that's awesome
i'll be saving one of these [__]
for you i can merry christmas to all the
church people you
and everybody who's going to enjoy this
i love you buddy have a great weekend
and we'll talk christmas eve i love you
too but
i'll call you then all right bye i'm
back i'm doing this i farted tremendous
on the patreon podcast
oh yeah oh my god it ripped the chair
apart it still stinks in there
i'll send you a whiff in the mail
[__] stay blind please do bye
buddy
all right you bad [__] i hope
you enjoy lee
and i hope you enjoyed me this year i
know there was a lot of rough spots but
uh
if you're new to this joint i love you
to death if you're an old church guy i
love you to death
and i don't give a [__] where you come
from as long that you enjoy me as much
as i enjoy doing this for you guys i
enjoy doing this
i enjoy taking you guys under my wing
and talking two hours a week if you've
noticed this year we cancelled the
podcast i don't want to give you a
three-hour podcast what's that gonna do
i'll give you an hour so you could
listen to all your other favorite shows
but i will make you one promise
2022 is our [__] year on the [__]
joint we're going to come at you with
different things our patreon is going to
change
everything is going to change this year
was a write-off for everybody
uh numbers are going back up i know a
lot of years are concerned
people are cancelling stuff who gives a
[__]
if you're going to have a party just
make people take a test that's it that
twenty one dollars i'll pay for the
[__] task for you to come over here
and feel relaxed i mean this omaron is
not a [__] joke and it is people
getting sick for three days they ain't
gonna [__] kill you
but you still don't want to ruin your
[__] holiday so stay in the next
couple days if you're going to go to
somebody's house go to walgreens go to
shoprite go to cvs buy yourself a little
[__] test make sure they're fine
so you don't get the whole family sick
this is just us taking care of one
another guys this is what this is all
about
you guys have always taken me care of me
and i've taken care of you there's a
two-way street so i wish you guys the
best christmas
the best [__] christmas day the best
christmas eve i wish you guys a great
[__] new year's party i want you to
stay safe
and i love you guys and i'm just looking
forward to 2022. thank you for always
having my back the patreon will have
podcasts next week i will do the 220
minute podcast
on patreon next week to just keep me
afloat if you want to join it's five
bucks for the [__] week whatever the
[__] you want to do i don't give a [__]
i just want you guys to be as excited as
i am
for 2022. i love you [__] with
all my heart thank you for supporting
the joint thank you for supporting the
church thank you for supporting one one
by one podcast thank you for supporting
mike's patreon everything is we're
grateful to you and don't forget to do
your grateful list before the new year i
love you [__]
have a great [__] day and stay the
[__] black love you
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank lisa i want to thank mike i
want to thank everybody who was a part
of this show this year but i want to
thank you guys for always having my back
before we leave listen draftkings is the
way to go this weekend it's the end of
the [__] year i want you to party
hardy i want you to win some money and
get your dick suck snorts and blow
whatever the [__] light your balls on
fire draft king sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the nba in the
nfl we got a gift for you listen
i don't [__]
really like doing this [__] but
sport draftkings have saved me
this year it's fun i only bet 25 dollars
a game i bet props they got everything
to cover your [__]
noodle there
all you got to do is bet five hours and
then the nba team and you're gonna win
150 and free bets and that's great
that's for the nba i'll get you the same
deal for pro football the same deal for
they're doing a thing on draftkings if
you bet five [__] college games you
get like a free [__] bet it's
tremendous and if sportsbook isn't
available in your state
listen your christmas is still going to
be merry with the draftkings daily
fantasy basketball contest draftkings is
giving all new customers a free shot at
millions of [__] dollars and
total prices off your first deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app or
the fantasy app and use promo code joey
that fantasy app is on fire they're
giving away millions of dollars on there
but on the sportsbook app just bet five
dollars on the nba team
and if they win i'm gonna give you 150
free bets that's promo code joey j-o-e-y
this christmas week at draftking sports
book i'm trying to put some money in
your pocket before [__] new year's
eve so you can do whatever you need to
do you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customer
supply minimum 5 deposit with a dollar
wager one per customers restrictions do
apply see draftkings.com
sportbook for details if you got a
gaming prom take care of it i don't want
you on this site getting into worse
situations call 1-800 gambler but first
head over to draftkings and let's win
some [__] getters [__]
the joint is also brought to you by c b
d lion
i'm getting purple in the face telling
you how good cbd lion is i mean i can't
keep telling you the rest is up to you
whether it's cream if you have a pain
anxiety whatever you might be going
through go to cbd lion read the third
party lab results they'll help you
determine what you get who else does
that for you that's why i'm with cbd
lion press and code joey and get 20
percent
off anything on there delivered right to
your house joey joint church and i do
this few [__] out of love i
want to thank
better help
stamps i want to thank [__] blue chew
i want to thank draftkings cbd lion
and lucy co and all other sponsors this
year
from manscape to [__] freezepipe.com
remember freeze pipe has a great
gift for you i love you [__]
i'll see you january 3rd
tip top magoo
stay black have a good holiday season
and i'll check in with you during the
week we'll be on twitter and facebook
stay black
[Music]
you